so quick democracy check the poll show
and these of course were taken before
the invasion that the vast majority of
americans oppose getting involved in the
conflict in ukraine dulce gabbard has
watched all of this in the beginning of
course she is military veteran currently
serving by the way a former member of
congress she's been denounced as a
foreign agent for speaking on behalf of
the majority of americans she joins us
tonight congressman thanks so much for
coming on um thank you so what what's
your reaction to what we've seen in the
past 24 hours
uh first of all
i do not in any way support putin's
decision to go into ukraine it is
causing and going to cause an immense
amount of suffering
for the people there i've been to
ukraine a few times i have personal
friends who are still in ukraine people
have nothing to do with politics
everyday ukrainians and they're afraid
tucker and they're angry they're angry
at russia they're angry at america and
they're angry at the failure of
leadership that could have prevented
this and that is the thing that is most
tragic about this heartbreaking
situation with this war is that
it could have been avoided if president
biden and nato had done exactly what you
were just talking about in agreeing hey
we're going to take nato off the table
for ukraine something that both the u.s
and nato have agreed is not likely to
ever happen and something that is a
legitimate security concern
for russia that they ca they won't
accept having u.s and nato troops on
their border within ukraine had the u.s
and nato leadership done this
this situation could have could have
been uh prevented
i think i think the the problem here in
america is that
uh people who bring this up people who
ask these questions people who challenge
the decisions that the biden
administration uh has been making in
this uh are are smeared and and
character
caricaturized as traitors
rather than actually pointing at the
truth which is
this administration is not acting in the
best interest the american people they
are turning their backs on the american
people
so now that the current policy has
failed and i don't know anybody who
thinks the invasion of ukraine is a good
thing
um
how volatile a situation is it i mean
people don't seem to want to address
that question but these things tend to
escalate in ways you don't anticipate
like sideways are you worried about that
i'm extremely concerned about it and
this is what you and i have talked about
in the days and weeks leading up to this
situation forecasting exactly what we
are seeing playing out today where you
see this back and forth where
you have the leader of russia and the
leader of the united states of america
saying hey yes if they cyber attack we
are going to attack back stronger this
escalation of a tit for tat will only
continue to increase and no one no one
in the bite administration the
leadership in this country is saying
where does this go where does it end
what what does it resolve and what will
it continue to cost the american people
the most dangerous thing is that we're
talking about an escalation of conflict
between the two great nuclear-armed
powers in the world who have nuclear
armed missiles at the ready prepared to
launch at a moment's notice and so
whether this this could get to that
point intentionally or mistakenly
through a miscalculation as we've seen
happen numerous times throughout history
this is the seriousness of the threat
that we're facing
i think that's nicely put kelsey gabbard
great to see you tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else